el partido demócrata de Estados Unidos
retiene el control del senado tras la
victoria de cátering Cortez masto en
Nevada en la cámara de representantes
los republicanos necesitan siete escaños
de los 20 que quedan por conocerse para
alcanzar la mayoría
las fuerzas ucranianas avanzan en la
retoma de gerson tras La retirada de las
tropas rusas de la orilla occidental del
río nieper fueron dimirselenski denunció
que el ejército de Moscú destruyó la
infraestructura crítica de la ciudad de
gerson antes de abandonarla
una explosión en Estambul causa al menos
seis muertos y más de 80 heridos el
presidente Turco declaró que información
preliminar apunta un ataque terrorista
Aunque ningún grupo ha reído indicado
los hechos Tenemos reporte desde
Estambul
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición en Estados Unidos
porque el partido demócrata mantiene el
control del senado tras la victoria de
Katherine Cortez masto en el estado de
Nevada en la composición actual los
demócratas cuentan con 50 escaños y los
republicanos con 49 Todavía queda un
escaño al senado por decidirse en la
segunda vuelta del estado de Georgia del
6 de diciembre pero aunque lo ganen los
republicanos y la cámara alta quede
dividida en 50 a 50 el voto de la
vicepresidenta kamala Harris
desempataría y otorgaría la mayoría a
los demócratas previamente hablamos con
Scott morgenstern profesor de ciencias
políticas en la universidad de Pittsburg
quien precisamente nos analizó Sí con la
mayoría demócrata y ha declarada en el
senado todavía es relevante la segunda
vuelta de Georgia
Sí por supuesto porque ellos tienen más
posibilidades no tienen que contar con
una persona como hemos tenido en los
últimos dos años que un senador que este
Western que es más conservador Entonces
siempre ha sido un debate con él
un intercambio difícil para que
pegue la [__] a los otros demócratas
entonces tenía una persona más ayuda
mucho a los demócratas devoción una cosa
más que el senado tiene poder de aprobar
los jueces entonces solo tener los 50
ahí tener la mayoría ahí ayuda mucho a
los demócratas con estos segundos la
segunda parte del mandato de baile
como avanzamos en los titulares el
control de la cámara de representantes
todavía no está decidido quedan 20
escaños por conocerse y los republicanos
solo necesitan siete para alcanzar la
mayoría un control republicano de la
cámara baja implicaría que la actual
presidente de este órgano legislativo la
demócrata Nancy pelosi sería reemplazada
en el cargo sin embargo pero si declaró
que pase lo que pase no tiene intención
de dejar el congreso repasamos su perfil
con el siguiente informe
una demócrata que desata amores y odios
Nancy pelosi la hasta ahora presidenta
de la cámara de representantes ha sido
pieza clave en las iniciativas de los
dirigentes de su partido
es un día feliz para nuestro país porque
Joe biden es un unificador porque está
decidido a unir a la gente
ejerció como líder de la cámara
inicialmente de 2007 a 2011 en 2010
ayudó a aprobar el famoso plan de salud
de Obama conocido como Obama Care en
2019 cuando volvió a liderazgo de la
cámara fue fundamental en los planes de
ayuda económica para los estadounidenses
afectados por la pandemia de Kobe 19 y
decisiva en los proyectos de Joe biden
Pero ha sido una piedra en el zapato
para su principal opositor el
expresidente Donald Trump a quien le
inició dos juicios políticos con el
ánimo de destituirlo el primero en 2019
por acusaciones de retención indebida de
ayuda militar a Ucrania y otro en 2021
por incitar el ataque del 6 de enero en
el Capitolio
hoy se produce un vergonzoso salto a
nuestra democracia sin embargo no puede
isodirnos de nuestra responsabilidad de
validar la elección de Joe biden
también ha sido fuerte en la política
exterior en agosto de este año enfureció
a China tras visitar la diputada isla de
Taiwán ser la cara más reconocida de la
cámara de representantes le ha causado
también problemas de seguridad en el
ataque al Capitolio la masa irrumpió en
su oficina mientras gritaba queremos a
Nancy Asimismo el 28 de octubre en su
casa en San Francisco un hombre atacó
brutalmente a su esposo con un martillo
mientras decía donde esta Nancy la
presidenta podría perder su cargo cuando
se defina quién será la mayoría de la
cámara de representantes vamos ahora con
información relativa a la Guerra de
Ucrania porque kiev restablece su
control sobre la ciudad de gerson tras
La retirada de las tropas de Moscú
recordemos que el viernes las fuerzas
especiales de Ucrania fueron las
primeras en entrar en la ciudad según
fue lo dimirsele el ejército ruso
destruyó la infraestructura crítica de
la urbe antes de abandonarla utilizar
todas sus tropas en una línea de defensa
a la orilla Oriental del río nyaper
distintos analistas consideran La
retirada rusa de jerson una táctica de
Cara a una eventual negociación más
detalles de la situación con Luis Muñoz
banderas ucranianas en gerson Jeff logra
la recuperación de una de las provincias
anexionadas por Rusia un lugar
estratégico para poder reconquistar
parte del territorio perdido tras la
invasión de Rusia
pone mucha más presión sobre crimea en
el sur y también no solo sobre crimea y
las fuerzas rusas allí sino también
sobre la flota rusa del mar Negro
esto ha puesto sus sistemas de armas a
distancia principalmente imas al alcance
una cantidad significativa del
territorio ucraniano que Rusia posee
actualmente
con la recuperación de jerson el
ejército ucraniano buscará después del
duro invierno llegar a las ciudades de
mérito Paul y Mario Paul para ello deben
cruzar margen Oriental del río niéper
donde Rusia ha montado su línea de
defensa con el abandono de jerson el
ejército ruso trata de reagruparse Y
aprovechar la Barrera natural del río y
evitar que Ucrania pueda cortar su
conexión terrestre con crimea en
palabras para France 24 el analista
Fernando cocho intuye tres posibilidades
en las intenciones del presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin Pero hay tres por
visibilidades que están manejando en
todos los análisis de inteligencia Y
seguridad uno que abandona gerson como
una especie de Berlín de los años 40
para ser la ciudad a partir de la cual
se pueda negociar con Ucrania un fin de
la guerra bajo la presión de Estados
Unidos China India entre otros una
segunda variante sería que se ha
refugiado en más en el profundo bombas
Putin porque jerson tampoco lo
necesitaba desde el punto de vista
geoestratégico y la tercera que pretenda
dar una señal hacia Ucrania que le haga
bajar sus exigencias a la hora de una
negociación tras la invasión Rusia
Ucrania del 24 de febrero Rusia logró el
control de gerson tras un ataque
Relámpago casi ocho meses después kiev
logra recuperar un territorio que está
lejos de la normalidad tras haber sido
minado saqueado y cuya infraestructura
clave ha sido destruida
y de la guerra en Ucrania también habló
en exclusiva para Franz 24 el presidente
de Colombia Gustavo Petro quien analizó
el impacto del conflicto en América
Latina precisamente esta semana en su
discurso ante la cop 27 en Egipto el
presidente colombiano pidió el fin de la
guerra
no observamos un juego tan
que fue propiciando la construcción de
una reacción rusa
y la reacción rusa se dio sobre un
pueblo que no tenía nada que ver ni con
la otan Ni color rusos que es el pueblo
ucraniano ese juego que también se quiso
imponer en la esquina suramericana la
que pertenezco cotán rusos la lucha
comercial Estados Unidos china no
representa los intereses de América
Latina
y en esa medida lo mejor que podemos
hacer nosotros es tomar distancia
y proponer La Paz
así fueron las palabras del presidente
de Colombia Gustavo Petro pueden ver la
entrevista completa en francés 24 esta
noche a las 7:20 hora de Bogotá quito
lima y Costa este de Estados Unidos
vamos ahora a la ciudad turca de
Estambul donde se produjo una explosión
que causó al menos seis muertos y
decenas de heridos a esta hora se
desconocen detalles de los hechos pero
el presidente del país receptáis
hiperdogan declaró que según información
preliminar parece un ataque bomba
nuestro corresponsal en Estambul adrià
Rocha con los detalles
seis fallecidos y dos que podrían ser
unos próximas horas es el balance casi
final del atentado ocurrido esta misma
tarde en la ciudad de Estambul en la
calle de isquitlán un centro neurálgico
de compras y de grandes almacenes en el
centro de la gran ciudad de Turquía
según explicado hace unos pocos minutos
el vicepresidente Turco fuet octay hay
83 heridos 30 de los cuales han sido ya
dados de alta del hospital quedan unos
50 hospitalizados de los cuales dos
están en estado crítico y se teme por
sus vidas Aunque podría ser que en las
próximas horas pudiesen recuperar según
ha explicado octay el autor de este
atentado ha sido una mujer ha dicho el
vicepresidente Turco que ha estado
sentado sentada en un banco en la calle
durante 40 minutos allí depositado una
bolsa que supuestamente contiene los
explosivos que después han causado dicha
explosión después han explotado justo
después de que esta mujer se saliese de
el lugar no se desconoce absolutamente
la identidad de esta supuesta mujer y a
la organización que pertenecería y que
podría ser detrás de este atentado ser
hipotiza con el estado islámico que
realizó muchísimos atentados en Turquía
sobre todo en 2016 y 2015 y también la
guerrilla Turco curda del pegaca algo no
tan habitual pero sí es cierto que
Turquía y esta guerra llevan en guerra
desde la década de los 80 y en la
actualidad están habiendo muchísimos
combates en contra de esta guerrilla
tanto en el norte de Siria como el norte
de Irak
y cuatro ciclistas argentinos
recorrieron unos Diez mil kilómetros
pedaleando desde Sudáfrica hasta Qatar
Para apoyar a su selección nacional en
el mundial de fútbol que empieza en una
semana nos lo cuenta Andrés trigueño
la locura mundialista Ya está presente
en Qatar un grupo de cuatro amigos
argentinos aventuró a recorrer 10.000
kilómetros desde Sudáfrica hasta Qatar
todo con un solo objetivo apoyar a su
selección doblemente mundialista
el Cuarteto argentino realizó un
recorrido de 177 días pedaleando casi
unos seis meses hasta llegar a un
desafío mayor fue el último que fue
cruzar el desierto de Arabia Saudita
tengo que hacer 2000 kilómetros
hicimos más o menos 150 kilómetros por
día y era levantarse comer algo y
desayunar salía de rutas además de
realizar este arduo recorrido el equipo
de toda pedal buscaba romper los
estereotipos sobre las personas de los
países por los que pasaban mientras
grababan imágenes para realizar un
documental Este es el último de una
serie de viajes de larga distancia que
los ciclistas han realizado para asistir
a importantes eventos deportivos como
los Juegos Olímpicos de Río 2016 y el
mundial de Rusia 2018 una aventura
increíble más que una aventura fue una
una escuela de vida pues impresionante
todas las cosas que hemos vivido todavía
no no procesamos no nos damos cuenta no
dimensionamos de de lo que hemos logrado
el equipo utilizó las redes sociales
para narrar su recorrido diario y pedir
ayudas a sus seguidores al llegar a doha
cientos de aficionados los esperaban
para animar su último tramo mientras el
comité de organización y legado de la
FIFA les daba la bienvenida después de
recorrer 10.000 kilómetros en bicicleta
cruzando África y medio oriente los
argentinos de todo a pedal llegaron a
Qatar Para apoyar a su elección en la
copa del mundo ahora el equipo de
ciclista se prepara para ver el debut de
su selección contra Arabia Saudita el 22
de noviembre en Los Ángeles Stadium
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros
[Música]